the laws of this YouTube channel are
mine and they will obey me so we're not
getting new Doctor Who stuff for a
little while yet and this time of year I
get into a doctor who gets usually and
we got new episodes around this time but
I am going to do something a little bit
different I'm gonna talk about an older
episode specifically I'm gonna talk
about the waters of Mars I'm doing this
for two reasons one we're in October
Halloween this is one of the scarier
once I think it's fitting but also one
of the most common questions I get
anyone who looks at either my top 10
stories of the 10th doctor list or my
top 10 one-time villains list I always
get one question where's water Mars
where's the flood and I'm really tired
of responding to those comments so I
just want to make a video explaining my
thoughts on this episode why it didn't
make either of those top two lists so
next time I can just comment back with a
link to this video and leave it at that
so waters of Mars is it good yes and
that's one of the things that drives me
nuts about the Internet do you do a top
10 list people didn't assume anything
that's not on your top 10
why don't you hate this I don't hate it
it just isn't top 10 material for me and
that's sort of where this fall's there's
a lot to like about this episode and
I'll start with the stuff that really
works David Tennant as a doctor doing
very well I mean he was on his way out
he was on the tail end this is part of
the specials and he knows he doesn't
have a lot of time left and he's putting
his all into it as he usually got I
didn't think he ever phoned it in I
don't want to imply that but you really
got the field during the specials like I
want to go how on a high note and this
one is really building well towards the
end of time parts 1 & 2 in terms of
where he is as a character and what's
going on inside of him and the conflicts
he's got going this episode also is a
really strong supporting cast and most
of my favorite Doctor Who stories have
excellent supporting cast something like
this or the same pit is another one with
a fantastic supporting cast you know all
these characters we haven't seen before
and we won't see again but have built-in
dynamics that are believable and they
react to the doctor in different ways
and it makes the whole thing just feel
much more organic it feels like a new
living world that the doctor is entered
into instead of what can happen with
more stiff and less interesting
supporting cast where it just feels like
these people are just here to service
the doctor story I think the environment
and the sets really won't realize I
think Mars looks great I definitely want
to single out the leader of the team
Adelaide Brooke she's wonderful I've
mentioned her on a top-10 list before
she is great
she's got wonderful gravitas and yet she
feels very human that she's got this
great balance of being a leader being
strong and yet still feeling vulnerable
and not being something implacable
badass like she is a human with concerns
and fears and hopes but at the same time
she knows how to get down and get the
job done okay so that's all this stuff
that's good so with all this stuff why
do I keep leaving this episode off of
top tens well two reasons the first is I
personally don't find it especially
scary it's effective in what it's trying
to do it's not like I'm laughing at it
like I was with something like Sleep No
More it's not that but it's just I want
I'm like oh interesting but I'm not
scared by it and I mean that's a
personal thing but whatever so does
trying to be scary and I'm not scared
that's gonna bring it down a little bit
then the other thing is the whole
concept of the flood which is fine
there's nothing wrong with it I don't
dislike it but I'm not gonna elevate it
up to the top 10 cents because as far as
I'm concerned it's a riff on zombies and
I've seen zombies today this basically
just got the water in places of infected
blood and again not a thing wrong with
that but just sort of feeling that they
are just such a zombie surrogate makes
me not think of them as highly and the
other thing I know I've seen some people
say you know just one drop of water and
you're doomed I need that's terrifying
to me that's actually not something
being that absolute in a way for me
makes it less scary
I find uncertainty to be very scary so
if I were to compare say the Vashta
Nerada if with the Batchelor neurotic
single shadow can eat you that thousands
I mean I get intellectually why that's a
scary situation to be in but that was a
concept doesn't scare me you've just
made this huge blanket statement it's
this absolute but the idea of no not
every shadow is bashing nerado but any
shadow could be that is much scarier to
me the the uncertainty of it that not
having no idea whether you're safe or
not the idea all the waters infecting
tussah water you're done kind of take
some of the tension out of it for me
because he isn't somebody gets wise my
okay well that's it so again it's very
much a personal thing I don't think
anybody's wrong if they put this episode
on a top 10 if they put the flood as a
top 10 monster it's all fine I don't
think either is bad it's just these are
some of the reasons that why I keep
leaving this stuff on my top 10 list
except for Adelaide burger
she made a top 10 list people seem to
forget that and I will stand by that but
you know what even though this didn't
personally frame me this is one of the
better executed scary stories that
modern doctor who has done so if you
want to pop in some Doctor Who it during
October getting revved up for Halloween
this works Blanc works midnight works
I think Hyde works although I get the
impression I like that episode more than
a lot of people but yeah that wasn't a
top 10 so for me either but in any case
those are my overall thoughts on waters
of Mars pop it in for the hot the for
Halloween it's it's worth that if
nothing else so what were your thoughts
on waters of Mars I think I'm gonna get
a lot of people telling me how dumb I am
and that my rationale is stupid but in
any case whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
councils of geeks follow the Council of
geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned